good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight it's pretty clear that
both of the country's political parties
have changed radically over the past few
years and they're changing still we
cover that every night in this show
Donald Trump of course has transformed
the GOP you may have read about it on
the Democratic side there been profound
changes to ones that don't get quite as
much attention a party that for a
hundred years stood with America's
middle class now represents the nation's
richest and it's poorest and so not
surprisingly the party's positions on
policy have changed accordingly a lot so
just about 20 years ago Democrats
champion free speech they worried about
illegal immigration loudly they
criticized voluntary Foreign Wars and
they argued that unrestricted trade hurt
American workers and by the way quite a
few of them Democrats were pro-life too
Senator Harry Reid among them and that's
not surprising if you think about it
Democrats said they cared most about the
vulnerable in our society even Bill
Clinton who vetoed to partial-birth
abortion bans felt the need to say he
wanted to keep abortion rare he said
that a lot try that in today's
Democratic Party lots of luck
modern democratic activists celebrate
abortion as a positive good shout your
abortion they proclaim they put it on
t-shirts abortion isn't bad we need more
of it well earlier this month Governor
Andrew Cuomo signed a bill making that
possible it's called the reproductive
health act and the law legalizes
abortion right to the moment of birth
for virtually any reason now to most
people aborting a child moments before
delivery might seem uncomfortably like
killing a lot of pro-choice people feel
that way it's a concern well Cuomo's law
addresses that concern the law declares
that children who have not yet been born
are not in fact human so don't worry
about it Cuomo illuminated the new world
trade center in lower Manhattan with
pink lights to celebrate the bill
signing he described it as a profound
moral victory now the national press
didn't spend a lot of time covering this
no matter how much you might like roe
v-- wade maybe you loved it
there's still something pretty
foolish about celebrating third term
abortion maybe that's why only a tiny
percentage of American voters support
around 13% small percentage nobody
really wants to hear the details about
any of this so nobody asks and that's
why the video we're about to show you
which is done Gouri don't worry but it
is remarkable in it a Virginia
Democratic lawmaker called Cathy Tran
explains in detail a bill she's
introduced that will remove all
restriction on late term abortion she
was asked for what would that mean
exactly
and Tran tells the truth watch this
where it's obvious that a woman is about
to give birth she has physical signs of
that she is about to give a birth would
that still be a point at which she could
request an abortion if she was so
certified she's dilating mr. chairman
that would be a you know a decision that
the doctor the physician and the women
understand that I'm asking if your bill
allows that my bill would allow that yes
so abortion at the point of dilation if
you're confused about what that means
ask anyone who has given birth and then
think about it for a second there's a
lot going on obviously but just think
about that for one second you may be
pro-choice are you okay with that
Virginia's governor is okay with that
he's thought about it Ralph Northam is
his name he's been in office a little
over a year he's often described in fact
always described as moderate and that's
pretty amazing given his reaction to
Kathie translates from abortion bill
this is from today watch this it's done
in cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a fetus that's
non-viable so in this particular example
if a mother is in labor I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mothers
a discussion about killing the infant
the infant he's directed enough to call
the infinite with the infant is but
again the infant would be delivered and
resuscitated if that's what the mother
desires quote in other words the
governor of Virginia has just told us in
public on camera that is okay to kill a
child after the child has been born that
used to be called infanticide not
rhetorically but literally infanticide
taking the life of a child who is
breathing the governor seems you to say
that did he must speak will you'd hope
but no he didn't
Ralph Northam is a physician he's a
pediatric neurologist in fact he's got
some clueless layman who mangled an
arrow all talking point this is really
what he thinks this is what his party
thinks though no one ever says it but
it's true this is the new moderate
pro-choice position you should know that